The debate over gun
control has deep roots
in the United States.
And the fatal shooting
in Washington DC
will most likely
heat that up again.
Thanks for tuning in
to D News everyone.
I'm Trace.
Police in Washington DC are
still gathering all the facts
as they investigate the
shooting at the US Navy Yard
earlier today.
At the time of
this recording, CNN
has reported that at
least 12 people died,
including one of the
suspected gunman.
During times of gun
violence, debates inevitably
rise about how guns
fit into our society.
A new study published
in the American Journal
of Public Health is
making a bold claim.
It says, states where gun
ownership is higher experience
a higher number of
firearm related homicides.
This flies directly in the
face of some gun advocates who
cite the 1998 book,
More Guns Less Crime
by John Lott Jr. Where gun
controls effect on crime
is thrown up against
a lot of data.
This book and others
like it contain data
from various sources
compiled in such a way as
to push gun ownership as
a more sensible solution
to deter crime.
This new three decade
data heavy study however,
indicates a
contradictory finding.
The Boston University
School of Public Health
looked at CDC records
from 1981 to 2010,
and found as the number of guns
in the state increased by 1%,
the number of homicides
with guns increased 0.9%.
The researchers pointed
out that they're not
saying that more guns causes
more killings in these places,
but that over three decades
the number of killings
and the number of guns were tied
into this is very similar pace.
The assertion isn't
particularly new.
The Harvard injury
control research center
found the same thing in 2012.
And their data showed
even when controlling
for every other variable, more
guns correlate to increased
homicides.
Even if you take the
whole United States out
of the reckoning and only
look at other countries,
they found that
since 1990 across 26
developed countries where
more guns were available
there were more homicides.
Other studies in
the last 10 years
have found similar results.
Regardless of how you come
down on the great gun debate,
these studies are compelling,
though not causal.
Not one of these studies
does claim or even can claim,
more guns means more homicide.
But guns and crime seem to
increase and decrease together
across race, gender, age, type
of crime, urbanization, alcohol
consumption, employment, and
income level in all counties,
cities, regions, states,
and countries studied.
Data like this
tends to put people
on both sides of the gun
debate on their warpaths.
Gun advocates claim since
the 1990s gun ownership has
increased and thus
crime has dropped.
And though that it's
true crime has dropped,
there is no way to prove
causality they're either.
A number of gun homicides
have dropped overall.
But so has all crime
in the United States.
And this Boston University
studied still applies.
So though crime is down
overall and gun homicide
is down overall, the greatest
number of gun homicides
are found where there
are a lot of guns around.
For some reason, we're not sure.
Researchers are
working on the answers
as to why right as we speak.
Check out the Pew
Research Center
social and demographic study for
some really interesting reasons
on why crime may be dropping.
So what do you
think of this study?
Share your thoughts
with us in the comments.
And hey, this is science.
So let's try to point to
actual signs here too guys.
And not just anecdotes
or personal experiences.
Let's have a discussion.
Thanks for watching
D News today.
Click Subscribe so
you can get more
D News every day of the week.